this video here is a groundbreaking
video for multiple reasons
one I'm going to introduce you to the
the variance of a sample which is
interesting in its own right and I'm
attempting to record this video in HD
and and hopefully you can see it bigger
and clearer than ever before but we'll
see how all of that goes so this is a
bit of an experiment so bear with me but
so just before we go into the variance
of a sample I think it's instructive to
review the variance of a population and
we can compare their formulas the
variance of a population and it's this
Greek letter Sigma lowercase Sigma
squared that means variance I know it's
weird that a variable already has a
squared in it you're not squaring the
variable this is the variable Sigma
squared means variance actually let me
write that down
that equals variance variance and that
is equal to if you take each data point
and we'll call them X sub I you take
each data point find out how far it is
from the mean of the population the mean
of the population you square it and then
you take the average of all of those so
you take the average you sum them all up
you go from I is equal to 1 so the from
the first point all the way to the nth
point and then to average you sum them
all up and then you divide by n so the
variance is the average of the squared
distances of each point from the mean
and just to give you the intuition again
it's essentially says on average how
roughly how far away are each of the
points from the middle that's the best
way to think about the variance now what
if we're dealing you know this was for a
population right and we said if we
wanted to figure out you know the
variance of men's heights in the country
it'd be very hard to figure out the
variance for the population you would
have to go and essentially measure
everyone's height 250 million people or
what if it's for some population where
it's just completely impossible to have
the data or some random variable and
we'll go more into that later
so a lot of times you actually want to
estimate this variance by taking the
variance of a sample same way that you
can never get the mean of a population
but maybe you want to estimate it by
getting the mean of a sample and we
learned that in that first video
so you know this is if that's the whole
population that's you know millions of
data points or even data points in the
future that you'll never be able to get
because it's a random variable so this
is the population population you might
just want to estimate things by looking
at a sample and this is actually what
most of inferential statistics is all
about figuring out descriptive
statistics about the sample and make
inferences about the population let me
try this drug on a hundred people and if
it seems to have statistically
significant results this drug will
probably work on the population as a
whole so that's what it's all about so
it's really important to understand this
notion of of a sample versus a
population and being able to find
statistics on a sample that for the most
part can describe the population or help
us estimate they call it the parameters
for the population so what's the what's
the mean of a let me rewrite these
definitions what's the mean of a
population I'll do it in that purple
purple for population the mean of a
population you just take each of the
data points so you take each of the data
points in the population
X I you sum them up you start with the
first data point and you go all the way
to the nth data point a divided by n you
sum them all up and divide by that's the
mean so and then you plug it into this
formula and you can see how far each
point is from that central point from
that mean and you get the variance now
what happens if we do it for a sample
well if we want to estimate the mean of
a population by somehow calculating a
mean for a sample the the best thing I
can think of and really these are kind
of engineered formulas these are human
being saying well what is the best way
to sample it well all we can do is
really take an average of our sample and
that's the sample mean and we learned in
the first video that that notation the
formula is almost identical to this it's
just the notation is different stead of
writing mu you write x with a line over
it sample mean is equal to once again
you take each of the data points now in
the sample not in the whole population
you sum them up from the first one and
then to the nth one right they're saying
that there are n data points in this
sample and then you divide it by the
number of data points you have
fair enough it's really the same formula
the way I took the mean of a population
if I just have a sample let me just take
the mean the same way it's probably a
good estimate of the mean of the
population now it gets interesting when
we talk about variance so your natural
reaction is okay I have this sample if I
want to estimate this the variance of
the population why don't I just apply
the same formula essentially to the
sample so I could say and this is
actually a sample variance they use it
they use the formula s s squared so
Sigma is kind of the Greek letter
equivalent of s so now when we're doing
with a sample we just write the S there
so this is sample variance let me write
that down sample variance sample
variance this is so we might just say
well maybe a good a good way to you know
take the sample variance is do it the
same way let's take the distance of each
points in the each of the points in the
sample find out how far it is from our
sample mean right here we used the
population mean but now we'll just use
the sample mean because that's all we
can have we don't know what the
population it mean is without looking at
the whole population take the square of
that that makes it positive and has
other properties which we'll go over
later and then take the average of all
of these squared distances so you take
it from some of them all up and there's
n of them to sum up write lowercase n
and you divide by lowercase n is it well
you know this is a good estimate but
whatever this variance is that might be
a good estimate for the population whole
and actually this is a this is what some
people often refer to when they talk
about sample variance and sometimes
it'll actually be referred to as this
they'll put a little lowercase n there
and the reason why I do that is because
we divided by n so you say Sal what's
the problem here and then the problem
and I'll give you the intuition because
this is actually something that used to
boggle my mind and I'm still frankly
struggling with the intuition behind it
well I have the intuition but more of
kind of rigorously proving it to myself
that this is definitely the case but
think about this if I have a bunch of
numbers and I'll draw a number line here
if I draw a number line here so let's
say you know then let's say I have a
bunch of numbers in my population so
let's say
going to randomly put a bunch of numbers
in my population and these the ones to
the right are bigger than ones to the
left and if I were to take a sample of
them right maybe I take you know the
sample it's random you're you actually
want to take a random sample you don't
want to be skewed in any way so you know
maybe I take this one this one this one
and that one right and then if I were to
take the mean of that number that number
that number to that right it'll be
someplace in the middle it might be
someplace over there and then if I
wanted to figure out the sample variance
using this formula I'd say okay this
distance squared plus this distance
squared plus this distance squared plus
that distance squared and average them
all out and then I would get this number
that that probably would be a pretty
good approximate approximation for the
variance of this entire population the
population of the mean is probably going
to be I don't know it might be pretty
close to this if we actually took all of
the data points in average no maybe
they're like here someplace and then if
you figure out the variance it probably
would be pretty close to the average of
all of these lines right all of the
sample variance distances right fair
enough so you say hey Sal this looks
pretty good now but there's one little
catch what if I mean there's always a
probability that instead of picking
these kind of fairly well distributed
numbers in my sample what if I happen to
pick this number this number and that
number is mine and let's say that number
as my sample well.when whatever your
sample is your sample mean is always
going to be in the middle of it right so
in this case your sample mean might be
right here so all of these numbers you
might say okay this number is not too
far from that number that number is not
too far and then that number is not too
far so your sample variance when you do
it this way it might turn out a little
bit low right because all of these
numbers they're pretty you know they're
almost by definition going to be pretty
close to the mean of each other but in
this case your sample your sample is
kind of skewed and the actual mean of
the population is out here someplace
so the actual variance of the sample if
you had actually known the mean I know
this is all a little confusing
if you'd actually known the mean you
would've said oh wow you would have
found these distances which would have
been a lot more right the whole point of
what I'm saying is when you take a
sample
there's some chance that your sample
mean is pretty close to the population
mean right maybe your sample mean is
here and your population mean is here
and then this formula will probably work
out pretty well at least given your
sample data points of figuring out what
the variance is but there's a company
you'll chance that your sample mean your
sample mean is always going to be within
your data sample right it's always going
to be the center of your data sample but
it's completely possible that the
population mean is outside of your data
sample it might have just been you know
you just happen to pick ones that that
don't contain the actual population mean
and then this sample variance calculate
this way will actually underestimate the
actual population variance right because
they're always going to be closer to
their own mean than they are to the
population mean and if you're
understanding frankly even like 10% of
this you are a very advanced statistic
student but I'm saying all of this to
just give you hopefully some intuition
to realize that this will often
underestimate this formula will often
underestimate the actual population
variance and there's a formula and this
is actually proven more rigorously than
I'll do it that is considered to be a
better or they'll call it an unbiased
estimate of the population variance or
the unbiased sample variance and
sometimes it's just denoted by the s
squared again
sometimes it's donated by this s n minus
1 squared and I'll show you why it's
almost the same thing you take each of
the data points figure out how far they
are from the sample mean from the sample
mean you square them and then you take
the average of those squared except for
one slight difference I equals 1 to I
equals n instead of dividing by n you
divide by a slightly smaller number you
divide by n minus 1 so when you divide
by n minus 1 instead of dividing by n
you're going to get a slightly larger
number here and it turns out that this
is actually a much better estimate and
one day I'm going to write a computer
program to to at least prove it to not
to myself experimentally that this is a
better estimate of the population
variance and you know you would
calculate it the same way you just
divide by n minus 1 the other way to
think about it and actually no no I'm
all out of time
I'll leave you there now in the next
video we'll do a couple of calculations
just so you don't get too overwhelmed
with these ideas cuz we're getting a
little bit abstract see in the next
video